just because we remove the word patient
from the statement doesn't mean we're
going to be impatient an increase in the
target range for the federal funds rate
remains unlikely at our next meeting in
April with continued improvement in
economic conditions however we do not
want to rule out the possibility that an
increase in the target range could be
warranted at subsequent meetings let me
emphasize however that the timing of the
initial increase in the target range
will depend on the committee's
assessment of incoming information we
anticipate that it will be appropriate
to raise the target range for the
federal funds rate when the committee
has seen further improvement in the
labor market and is reasonably confident
confident that inflation will move back
to its two percent objective over the
medium term the committee continues to
expect a moderate pace of GDP growth
with robust job gains my colleagues and
I continue to expect that as the effects
of these transitory factors dissipate
and as the labor market improves further
inflation will move gradually back
toward our two percent of two percent
objective let me emphasize again the
today's modification of the forward
guidance should not be read as
indicating that the committee has
decided on the timing of the initial
increase in the target range for the
federal funds rate in particular this
change does not mean that an increase
will necessarily occur in June although
we can't rule that out